si analizamos una comunidad que se
encuentra en un cierto hábitat es
natural preguntarse si esa comunidad
siempre ha sido así y siempre ha estado
ahí hubo algún momento en el que no
había vida ahí y la respuesta es si las
comunidades cambian con el tiempo y hay
un periodo inicial en el que no existía
vida en ese hábitat que después la vida
colonizó lentamente y esa vida cambió
con el tiempo y bueno a eso se le conoce
como sucesión ecológica sucesión
ecológica
muchas veces escucharán hablar de los
diferentes tipos de sucesión ecológica
que se dividen en varias categorías la
primera es la sucesión ecológica
primaria que es el caso en el que
primero existe un hábitat nuevo y
después la vida lo coloniza lentamente y
uno de los mejores ejemplos de eso es
cuando se forman nuevas tierras a partir
de lava aquí tenemos algunas imágenes de
hawai en donde se forman nuevas tierras
y conforme se solidifica esa lava bueno
al principio cuando es lava fundida no
hay vida pero cuando la lava se endurece
la vida
lentamente coloniza la roca volcánica y
muchas veces no podremos verla a simple
vista necesitaremos usar microscopios
pero muchas veces podemos ver la
presencia de vida en forma de helechos y
plantas como esas y generalmente se les
conoce como especies pioneras y lo que
hacen es ayudar a que el medio ambiente
sea más apto para otros tipos de vida
por ejemplo puede ser que
mente vayan agrietando la roca y
conforme estas plantas van muriendo y la
roca se agrieta más y todo esto es
erosionado por el agua el aire y la
lluvia poco a poco comienza a hacerse la
tierra y las condiciones van siendo
idóneas para otro tipo de especies y
bueno estas especies pioneras no
solamente tienen que ser plantas y
microbios hace poco estaba leyendo un
artículo sobre que en hawai los humanos
quieren ser dueños de esta tierra que se
encuentra frente a la playa bueno más
bien la playa todavía no se ha formado
oficialmente pero finalmente es una
vista al mar así que en este caso los
humanos podrían ser algunas de las
especies pioneras que quieren estar
primero en esa tierra y bueno una tierra
nueva no se forma únicamente a partir de
lava existen otros ejemplos de la
formación de nuevos hábitats miren aquí
tenemos algunas imágenes de la formación
de nuevos hábitats mediante el
derretimiento de los glaciares cuando
los glaciares cubren todas estas rocas
no hay vida ahí pero conforme el glaciar
se derrite y de alguna manera podemos
decir que se retira de la tierra como
ocurre aquí podemos encontrar algo como
estos musgos y otro tipo de especies
pioneras que empiezan a colonizar la
tierra y que con el tiempo harán que
este lugar sea apto para otro tipo de
especies entonces esa es la sucesión
primaria pero otra situación es cuando
ocurre la sucesión secundaria hay muchas
formas en las que puede existir la
sucesión secundaria y uno de los
ejemplos más citados es cuando ocurre
algún tipo de desastre por ejemplo aquí
tenemos una fotografía de un incendio y
aquí estamos hablando de sucesión
secundaria
secundaria aquí existía una comunidad
pero cuando ocurrió el incendio eso
probablemente aniquiló a gran parte de
la comunidad pero a su vez creó el
espacio para que se formaran otras cosas
entonces después de que ocurrió el
incendio el bosque se veía así pero eso
permite que ahora más especies empiecen
a colonizar algo en donde otras especies
probablemente murieron durante el
incendio y muchas veces después de un
desastre como éste tal vez queramos
regresar al mismo tipo de comunidad que
había antes del desastre pero
generalmente se forma una completamente
diferente porque las comunidades no se
forman exactamente igual siempre así que
la idea general es que las comunidades
cambian con el tiempo ocurre la sucesión
ecológica entonces cuando originalmente
no hay ninguna comunidad a eso se le
llama sucesión primaria y la sucesión
secundaria es cuando ocurren desastres
de algún tipo que cambian el ambiente y
cambian la comunidad
aunque las cosas no tienen que ser
siempre tan dramáticas como la formación
de nuevas tierras mediante lava oa causa
de incendios forestales o incluso por la
regresión de los glaciares también puede
ser por causa de alguna enfermedad o
simplemente porque de alguna forma
surgen nuevas especies que lo cambian
todo la estructura la competencia la
depredación la variedad y las dinámicas
simbióticas en esa comunidad